- Ich glaube nicht, dass „Jan im Sack“ ein
Gericht aus Baden-Württemberg ist.
- Hier steht „eine Spezialität
der Stadt Oldenburg“.
- Ach und Oldenburg liegt in
Baden-Württemberg?
- Ja. Also, dachte ich.
- Du bist nicht nur im falschen Bundesland,
du bist in der komplett falschen Region.
Oldenburg liegt im Nordwesten
des Bundeslandes Niedersachsen.
- Oh, ups …
Hey, Nico.
- Hey, ich suche mein Vokabelheft.
Hab' ich es zufällig hier liegen lassen?
- Ja. Im linken Schrank unter der Theke.
- Super. Ich brauche es nämlich,
weil ich später meine B1-Prüfung habe.
- Echt? Viel Erfolg!
- Danke!
- Yara hat dich gestern gesucht.
- Hat sich alles schon geklärt. Ähm …
Jan im Sack?
Was macht ihr hier?
- Ahm, wir suchen klassische deutsche
Gerichte mit total verrückten Namen.
Wie „tote Oma“.
- Wir erklären die Herkunft des
Gerichts und wie man es zubereitet.
Und die Videos stellen
wir dann ins Internet.
- Coole Idee!
- Danke!
- Viel Erfolg!
- Also … woher kommt „kalter Hund“?
- Kalter Hund …